old month it is from India I am drinking
the liquor of my ancestry no you're
Indian I don't know with these three X's
though and it's pornographic xxx namaste
a little bit stronger than I expected
it's good rum
it's got like almost a maple syrupy
thing to it I was like really alone and
sadder throw this on my pancakes
it's like eating Indian food but in a
liquor form you just keep some Indian
rum good Jinro Tidrow from Korea you're
in the same terminal as a Cinnabon 24
percent looks like a lot like a strong
one if you take full shots of it it's
like how about all content so you can
just throw him back
jindol wait that's the easiest shot I've
ever taken I almost mistake it for water
I could drink that all day reminds me
I'm just like a much more reserved Surat
love me some general what is this called
mo tie-in baby
Wow new toy Naya is this the one with
the snake inside of it how much you like
percentage of liquors in it a staggering
106 proof it comes out like a cleaning
product this is Chinese Everclear Oh God
oh my god it smells like someone farted
on like some fruit roll-ups oh oh oh my
god it tastes like poison it's like a
divorce in my mouth under no
circumstances should this be consumed I
gotta be honest I like by Jim are you
that those great
yoga team new guy the packaging reminds
me of leg a prop from Howl's Moving
Castle select chocolate yeah like you're
that chocolate chocolate like a that's
so smooth I don't know what else to say
except hmm it's not very alcoholic it's
not like a liquor it's more like a wine
yes good it's very similar to the soju
it's the soju vibe with the mouth type
flavor yeah Japan wins always thorough
you want some yoga chai Mogu what's up
Mekong enjoyed with friends this is my
favorite looking bottle this looks like
something from like Casablanca CD
Thailand underbelly people are drinking
this kickboxing and Mekong that's what
Thailand does it smells good actually it
smells like Jameson's yeah it smells
like vodka know if someone quit Thai
iced tea in like Grey Goose you know a
Jew likes to get drunk just like the
rest of us right we've got bad alcohol
that gets the job done they've got bad
alcohol it gets the job done the other
day we're all just trying to get silly